what's up
reject nation greg alba here thank you
so much for clicking on this video
means a lot to have you here today so i
actually have something
very personal and very exciting to share
with all of you today if you've been
following me on youtube for a while now
it's pretty apparent my main passion
it's in movies and you might have heard
me say this before but specifically
my main drive is actually in
screenwriting and now
i might just be able to turn that dream
into a reality see when we started this
channel initially it was meant to just
be a stepping stone i didn't think it
would actually be a major part of my
career pursuits and of course
none of the success we've had would be
possible without your support which i'm
forever grateful for because after
several years
i still love making videos and the
channel's not going away anytime soon
however i never lost sight of my actual
goal
which was to one day graduate from you
know just
talking about movies and actually making
movies
now how did i finally get to this point
a couple years ago i became friends with
joel harlow he's an academy award winner
a key makeup and special effects artist
who's worked on such films like the
pirates of the caribbean trilogy
black panther the star trek films
logan a whole bunch of movies and shows
too many
name right now but for sure you've seen
his work in fact he was on this channel
once before
the biggest accomplishment out of his
whole career he uh reached out to me
about developing an idea of his
and turning it into a feature film
within the horror genre and of course
i said yes i mean i mean why wouldn't i
i mean he's the key makeup artist for i
love you philip morris fortunately
the whole team behind it is cool with me
talking about it right here on the
channel so i wanted to give you guys a
first look
at who's involved and what we've got
cooking for a new horror anthology
called old time radio i can't believe
i'm finally talking about this it's
going to have three full original
stories as well as a wrap around tale
that ties it together the script's
already been written and if you guys
want a taste for what we have in store
we just launched our official website
called oldtimerradiohorror.net
there you'll find story details and
concept art for our three
sinister tales some behind the scenes
images and videos as well as a proof of
concept short film introducing you
to the film's wraparound tale the latter
of which i
highly encourage you to go check out the
movie was written by
yours truly my buddy patrick hogue whose
horror short film called so you might
have seen on crypt tv
and joel harlow himself producer lloyd
levin is currently working with us and i
think i'm saying his name right i really
ought to know if i'm saying his name
right i should have fact checked that
11. he's produced the watchmen movie and
series the hellboy franchise and one of
my all-time favorite movies
boogie nights this film is like a
spiritual sequel to boogie night it's
not
basically with this movie what we want
to do is give a fresh spin
on a horror anthology merge it with the
atmospheric elements of a classic radio
horror drama while also delivering an
original film
with nuanced characters and of course
keeping it scary so
if you want a glimpse into the morbidly
nostalgic world that we've created i put
a link in the description box and pinned
comment to the short film that's
inspired by the wraparound tale the
story takes place on halloween evening
where decrepit housemates rick kissgrim
and edward
d mize engage in their annual tradition
feverishly awaiting a new trio of tales
from their possessed
old time radio so how it works in the
movie every time we drift into the
glowing dial of the crossley cathedral
radio the voice of our host
introduces another horror tale
can you count how many times i've said
horror
in this video did you guys know it was a
horror film oh yeah i should have
mentioned this earlier
but you know the segway is just too good
of an opportunity to pass up the host is
being played by none other
than paul giamatti that is not dream
casting
that is real we told him it was sideways
too but back to the actual movie
pat patrick i call him pat pat wrote the
first anthology tale
scarecrow i wrote the other two which
are titled live bait and chicken heart
like i've mentioned it's inspired by the
vintage horror radio classics of
yesteryear but in all honesty it serves
as more than just a trip down nostalgia
lane each story's focused on characters
and plot are
very different from one another they
each have its own unique tones
themes and just overall flavor can't
even say they're all the same kind of
horror you can go to the website to read
through the plot and story details and
check out some awesome
concept art that we have all that fun
stuff anyway i could
spend all night telling you guys about
all the details but i'll end it with
this
if you've made it this far first off
thank you for listening
everything i have talked about is all
linked in the description box and pinned
comment
for you boys and girls for the reject
nation to go ahead and check out we've
been working hard
you gotta walk hard we've been working
very hard and diligently
and i really can't wait for old time
radio to be brought to life and for you
guys to be a part of the journey all i
really ask is that you cruise the site
and if you like what you see
leave a comment or if just hearing me
talk about this is making you want to
see this film
leave a comment here or on the short
film engagement algorithm it all helps
sincerely i mean it if it wasn't for all
the support you've shown me over the
years
i wouldn't have the confidence to go out
and achieve the next steps and take some
chances
so in all sincerity i wouldn't be here
talking about any of this if it wasn't
for all of you
thank you again and
go check out the goddamn website